Berühmt sein?
Man verdient viel Geld.
Man kommt raus aus dem Image
'Mensch mit Beeinträchtigung'.
Denen laufen die Frauen
hinterher wie die Hühner.
Jede möchte mit den
Schauspielern 'etwas' haben.
Das wäre für dich ein Traum?
Ja, weil ich bin noch Single!
Ich möchte mal nach Hollywood.
Und dort bei einm Film
mitmachen, später einmal.
Warum ich gerne berühmt sein
möchte ist einfach ...
... ich mache das gerne
und das ist mein Hobby.
Ich würde gerne wissen, wie
das Gefühl ist, ...
... auf der ganzen Welt
bekannt zu sein.
Auf dem Roten Teppich
mit Limousine und vielen ...
... Hollywoodstars, das würde
ich gerne auch mal mitmachen.
Über den Roten Teppich würde
gerne mal laufen.
Das würde ich sehr
gerne einmal machen.
Auch mit Frauen dabei. Und einen
Oscar-Pokal möchte ich haben.
Ich fühle mich so gut im Herz.
Ja, voll. Ich fühle mich
wie im siebten Himmel.
Wohin du auch immer gehst,
nimm mich mit.
Ich bin deine Frau, die
immer auf deiner Seite ist.